- So, have y'all ever met before?
- No!
- We've never met.
We've met on the internet.
We've never met in person.
- I am having the experience
that you're having
with Kelly, I'm having
it about you right now.
- We're all having, it's
a love-filled day today.
- I just have to say, as a fellow person
in the queer community,
I am so amazed by you.
I think the fact that
the Human Rights Campaign
is honoring you is not enough.
I'm gonna cry!
It's gonna happen!
- No.
- I just think that your work in general
is so beautiful and so thrilling,
but the thing that you've done,
which I think is so incredible
is that you've introduced
audiences to this character
who just so happens to be who he is.
And like, that is the
way to create change,
social change, empathy in people.
It's so incredible!
- Likewise.
Likewise with you.
And you're an amazing woman.
- I mean, I can't even tell you.
- I thought that I was the
most excited to see him today,
but I have competition.
First of all, you look stunning.
- Oh thank you so much.
- You are like, I mean,
whatever this little number
you put together.
- It's periwinkle.
- It's very comfortable,
- Certified vision, yep.
- thanks guys, thanks.
Thank you.
- Okay, but wait, your
character on Brooklyn 99
is openly bi, and like
you were discussing,
like how do you think, 'cause I feel like
when you do, you're correct,
when you introduce these characters
on normal everyday television,
it makes people not fear
what they don't know.
And almost open up to be
like everyone's not the same,
and that's okay.
Do you think it's kind of
helped with that impact?
- I absolutely think so.
I mean, it really is
like spoon full of sugar,
you know what I mean, like
we got you with those laughs.
And then we're gonna
keep you comin', right.
And by the time that you've
most of the times, I think it
was first season for you guys,
right, first or second
season were you introduced?
- First season, yeah.
- Okay, so by the time
you've introduced it,
you've already got the
audience like in love with you.
They already know you, they trust you,
you're funny, you're having a good time.
And then suddenly for
maybe quite a few people,
they've never met anybody,
you're gonna be the fist
person that they're meeting
that is that, that identifies
that way or is that sexuality.
And for me specifically, it was like
there's just so little
representation across the board
for Latinas in television,
Latinas in film,
and so for me to be
Latina and queer and bi
and be playing a bi character
and also be openly bi myself,
is like, it's a lot of stuff.
- And do such a beautiful job.
- Oh thanks!
- [Kelly] Hey, thanks!
- Yeah, a really beautiful job.
- Hey, thanks!